[Music]
foreign
yay but there's one problem there's a
human has a mustache just like you
do you think I know every human being
with a mustache wearing an identical
outfit with a hat with the letter of his
first name on it because I don't
is coming
together we
are going to stop that monster how look
at us we're
able
I got this no problem
yes
Mario's our big adventure begins now ah
get it out get it out get it off
there's a huge Universe out there
there's a lot of galaxies
they're all counting on us
no pressure
wahoo
[Music]
these Rings signify the commitment
sorry sorry
life or death situation I need you to
use the ring to save me like right now
no my God
ah Hawaii I just hope we are not too
late oh Lord there are two of them now
what's happening okay quick version
Robotnik is back
I discovered the source of ultimate
power
we need to get it back before the world
is Doom
you brought some kind of
space porcupine I am an Echidna Warrior
hmm
Hedgehog It's Time to Say Goodbye to
humanity
welcome
to the new Norm
I should be the big hero bad time to say
this but I don't actually have a plan
hey you got a little something on your
uh someone call an Uber it's cold in
here
let's turn up the heat
oh great the Winter Soldier
fear not citizens you are terrible at
this your negative attitude is not
helping
untrained unworthy
you forgot one
Unstoppable
[Music]
s you are really bad at punching
welcome
to rhyme City a celebration of the
harmony between humans and Pokemon
Tim your dad was a legend in this
project
if you are anything like you're done
I remember you wanted to be a Pokemon
trainer when you were young
yeah that didn't really work out
[Music]
someone there
whoever you are I know how to use this
oh geez here we go I know you can't
understand me but put down the stapler
or I I will electrocute you
did you just talk whoa
because you just understand me oh my God
you can understand me that I've been so
lonely they tried to talk to me all the
time all they hear is pika pika you can
hear him right big America yeah
he's adorable you're adorable they can't
understand me kid no one else hear him
[Music]
oh come on period and what about a
world-class detective because if you
want to find your pops I'm your best bet
gonna do this
with me
[Music]
there's magic that brought us together
and that magic is called hope
listen up man we got ways to make you
talk or mine yeah so tell us what we
want to know
pipe yes okay I can shoving pushing my
problem is that I push people away and
then hate them for leaving he's saying
you can shove it what I can shove it
okay that's it no we're switching roles
I'm bad cop you're going
to go in my head I saw that differently
[Music]
There Are Places out there you can't
find on any map
they're not gone
are just lost
thank you a little young for a bartender
aren't you a little old for prom aren't
you
stay in here why the map this this for
Nam Magellan took the sale around the
world you know your history the biggest
treasure that's never been found five
billion easy
I think you're here because you're your
brother well you know my brother said
[Music]
I really
find that gold you find him too
the hell is this I'm a friend of Sully's
Sally doesn't have any friends I should
know I'm one of them
[Music]
well I dabble I'm
my family has been looking
so much blood
I'm pretty sure he just threatened to
kill me but don't touch your ear like
that you look like an idiot you have no
idea who you're partnered with
I've been dreaming about this stuff
since I was a kid my brother say I love
one final clue
[Music]
all right
welcome
what
crap
exclusively in movie theaters
my name's bracket Ralph 30 years I've
been doing this I can fix
it's hard to love your job when no one
else seems to like you for doing it
the bad guy who wrecks the building
I'm okay I'm okay
if I'm really honest with myself
sure must be nice being the good guy
what up you are bad guy but this not
mean your your bad guy I don't want to
be the bad guy anymore
abandon his game welcome to Game Central
Station Everything Changes Now
where's Ralph sorry cubers
Ralph's gone to Heroes Duty here is a
four-letter word ladies you want to go
pee pee in your big boy slacks keep it
to yourself
sister you're not from here are you
sugar rush your game chopping hey you
wouldn't hit a guy with glasses would
you you hit a guy with glasses well
played Without Ralph we're doomed
they're gonna pull our plug what's that
a metal I earned it in Hero's Duty it's
not that kind of Duty I bet you really
gotta watch where you step in a game
goes Duty
[Music]
we can't change who we are you can't
mess with the program Ralph
everyone here says I'm just a mistake
you ready for this
not leaving you here alone
[Music]
let's close out with the bad guy
affirmation I am bad and that's sort of
it I will never be good and that's not
bad oh that thought there's no one I'd
rather be in me
why do I fix everything I touch it's
make your mama's proud time
what are you doing one game at a time
around
I thought I saw that again
I'm going mad
[Music]
Lara your father's gone
at some point we have to face up to Who
We Are
who we're meant to be
I think I know where my dad went that's
right in the middle of the devil's seat
it will be an adventure
it's not an adventure
what are you doing here Laura
seven years I've been on this island
your father he put me here
now I see the likeness intelligence the
recklessness
about my son
[Music]
Laura there was one of my life than
boardrooms and business deals
[Music]
there's an organization called Trinity
looking to start a global genocide
Junior had a bigger holiday had a knack
for the unexpected
you must stop them Laura promise me
[Music]
ladies first
open the tube
put it down put your fingers pulling
this trigger you messed with the wrong
family
all right
[Music]
hey it's me red you know the guy
everybody hated
who kind of saved the whole island
anyway war with Leonard and the pigs
what are you gonna do I'm a foodie still
going on those pigs are gonna pay for
our lunches
what and Bob and Chuck are doing
yeah whatever they do I eat dirt
[Laughter]
and me well I still have some anger
issues but I'm finding healthier ways to
deal with it hello
Brad I know we've had our differences
but we've discovered that there's a
third island
in their body to destroy us all oh crap
let's give me one good reason why I
should believe you and I'll show you the
proof squeal teams
really we practice this 100 times
I have to get a team together guys this
is my sister silver I just don't think
you're gonna be compatible with the team
oh wow it is such a pleasure to meet not
you but you I like her we gotta get to
the island is what my assistant was
going to say assisted
oh my God
foreign
[Music]
well that's disappointing
step one we're gonna break in and
deactivate the weapon we look amazing we
gotta get that key card
hello fellow Eagle God oh no he's doing
a voice
yeah I'm just gonna
oh
[Music]
for our freedom and yours
some alien life force
has sent real life video games
attack us
[Applause]
[Music]
Pac-Man's a bad guy
incoming
Donkey Kong
it's just a barrel how bad can it hurt
the only way to take down Pac-Man is
with ghosts
these are your ghosts
oh yeah
we're the only ones who can do this
I'm kidding we are all gonna die
I'm just sorry
may I introduce to you Professor iwatani
the creator of Pac-Man
come on it's not about your
Professor Tony what are you doing I
would talk to him he's my son
hello my sweet little boy look how big
you've grown it's
I know
you're a good boy
a rescue George he was two years old
he's not just a friend
he's family don't move a muscle are you
crazy no don't move
okay very funny you and I laughing at
your joke new guy he no laugh
cry you can get up now and check your
diaper come on let's go
got your message about George you okay I
don't know George
it's okay
it's the mirrors he considerably bigger
no he's definitely bigger I need to find
someone who knows exactly what the hell
this thing is I found her nope that's a
lie technically she found us what's
happening to my friend are you familiar
with genetic editing
changes will be incredibly unpredictable
increase strength George speed agility
no
try to tell some change they can't run
where's George I need to see him he is
dangerous
we've created the next chapter in
natural selection project Rampage Works
we've got another one of your little
science experiments running around what
do you mean another one
of course the wolf flies
and give people the hell out of that
City let's go save the world
it's a big arm don't fight it I know
there are other ways of dealing with
people right
I do know that yeah but that's no fun
George you okay ready to do this buddy
[Music]
for years
our world has been at peace
something is coming
I can feel it
[Music]
dark force observe upon us
find these beasts or whatever they are
our world is dying
there is nothing to go back to
if our people are to survive
you must make a home here
whatever happens
[Music]
if we do not unite our world will perish
this doesn't need
that there is one who may help us for
Orcs
help there could be why are you here to
save our people
can we trust him
they're beasts
they should all be destroyed
are you sure about that
[Music]
we'll protect a kingdom you and I
this is suicide we have no choice we
should attack with full force
whatever you plan to do do it now
[Music]
this is no ordinary dagger
releasing the sand turns back time
only the holder of the dagger is aware
of what's happened
did you see that
[Music]
Prince Destin
have you wondered how you could have
found such a treasure are you not
curious why an orphan from the streets
could be chosen to become a prince the
gods have a plan for you a destiny there
are those who would use the power of the
daggered
to destroy the world
time will erase everything
you must protect it
who were these
[Music]
these quick deaths
the secret Guardian Temple
the one place the dagger can be safely
hidden he
[Music]
really enjoyed telling me what to do
don't you only because you're so good at
following orders yeah don't Press Your
Luck
[Music]
the DACA must be found
such a noble Prince
leaping to assist the Fallen Beauty
who said you were a beauty there must be
a reason why you can't take your eyes
off me you're I
it's time
how did you do that
that's impossible
difficult not impossible
snowshoes what people do that you know
fun fact not only is it the oldest but
remains one of the most effective means
of traversing the ice wow yeah you're
gonna fit right in at Beaver field
everything here is a little
[Music]
questionable Ranger the people
the weather
everything
[Music]
oh
creature you look like you just seen a
corpse well the roads are out and
something's wrong with the generator
which generator all of them make it on
the internet
uh also
there's a dead body under your porch
[Applause]
probably a wolf what are you like a wolf
detector now Marcus who knows
when
I gotta kill next
I think we can all agree that it's
unsafe outside and there's safety in
numbers out of curiosity who is packing
well we're having a good old-fashioned
sleepover
with guns though with guns yes
everything about this Predator is an
orthodox it's not human it's
one of them one of what
how did they get out
who says he got out
maybe I'm a werewolf maybe you're a
werewolf maybe you're a werewolves
are we really in a Mexican standoff
right now baby
[Applause]
you know we're probably just gonna head
out just pull it okay
[Music]
you're here to save my soul
I understand it's your birthday
yeah
the party's just getting started
[Applause]
his name is Callum ninja
we've traced his bloodline back 500
years to the Assassin's Creed
[Music]
[Applause]
Cal has anyone in the world knows or
cares you no longer exist
[Music]
what is this place
this is your second chance
[Music]
not for me your past you're about to
enter the Animus what you see hear and
feel are the memories of your ancestor
who's been dead for 500 years wait a
minute
welcome to the Spanish Inquisition
it was
you're watching you waiting to see who
you are
I believe you are destined for great
things let's find out
[Music]
we work in the darkness
we are assassins
[__]
I'm beginning to like this
[Applause]
Captain you have any idea what those
markers are they look pretty ancient
tracks in here it's definitely bravo
team they don't just disappear
foreign
where the hell are we that lightning and
hit those markers and it took us
somewhere
guys
so what are we like Guardians of the
Galaxy now
oh that's six
yeah Bros
all right
did you see that thing
go back
this is officially above my pay grade
disarm
Ed
I'm getting us all home
foreign
[Music]
first learned about this seven years ago
on a mission in Brazil to capture a
wanted Fugitive
out there it tore through our unit in
seconds
the target has superhuman abilities
[Applause]
thank you
the same Market you do Cole
what's the birthmark what do you mean he
was born with it it's not a birthmark
Cole
means you've been chosen
throughout history different cultures
all over the world
reference a great tournament
champions
a dragon markings
something known
[Applause]
as Mortal Kombat
these are your Champions I'm Sonia
that's Kano I'm Luke
Miss Jackson
the fate of Earth is in our heads
no matter how many of my people you put
in the ground
not fail
[Music]
Sub-Zero
[Applause]
before
get over here
kind of wins you [__] Beauty
[Music]
thank you